i mentioned to you offline that i spent
a bit of time with some robots and
boston dynamics do you think there's a
way to use artificial intelligence to
help
so data collection so automating some of
the
some of the things that makes humans
special make some of that decision some
of that memory that's then utilized
converted into knowledge to make
decisions about the crops and so on
is there a way if ai can help do you
think i totally
i mean that's that's that would be
incredible that's one of the
ingredients that could help with the
regenerative number of discrete decision
points
that could completely be automated
as well in order to supplement and work
with somebody like a farmer in managing
it
about the the the performance on land
and a bit of that's being done right now
with some
aerial mapping and but that type of ai
would be
huge in this i mean there's estimates
that if
the um damage and underutilized
rangeland
in the world was converted to
regenerative agriculture at somewhere
between
like 20 and 40 of the world's carbon
could be sequestered
so there's a huge potential the problem
is
cultural we've
like lost the generational threat of
knowledge about how to do this it's kind
of been two generations that haven't
farmed this way
also the science around it is
limited by the scale and longevity so
the data
collection around regenerative farming
is also limited by the fact it's kind of
piecemeal
there's small operations that are doing
it they're learning and developing as
they go
and they haven't been documenting it and
doing it for too long
you